so the question is how do you become
satisfied is it just consuming more fat
is it eating more nutrient dense foods
is it making sure that your digestion is
working like you have enough bile to
extract these fat soluble nutrients and
these are all things that I've talked
about in other videos but I haven't
talked about the biggest thing that's
going to satisfy your hunger and this is
based on a recent book with some
fascinating new information I'm going to
put that link down below but this book
talks about this one concept called
protein leverage hypothesis and
basically they studied insects and they
found that certain insects will continue
to eat
until their protein requirements are met
and if you put these insects on a low
protein diet they will overeat okay to
get that protein need and this is very
interesting because one of the devices
that I give people is to make sure you
have your salad first before you consume
your protein because if you have your
protein first the odds of you finishing
that salad are much less so protein
tends to make you satisfied and it's
really not the protein it's the amino
acids in the protein so let's just take
a look at protein and what what actually
it does for your body well number one
you know it replenishes your muscles
your ligaments your tendons your
collagen your skin your bone but not
just that
all of your enzymes not just for
digestion but all the biochemistry is
made with proteins your cells are made
out of proteins your blood is protein
your most of your hormones are protein
so as a survival mechanism there's a lot
of importance on protein especially
since you don't store your protein and
so if you don't eat protein where does
it come from right well it comes from
your muscles but not initially okay when
you do prolonged fasting where does a
lot of your protein come from it comes
from damaged protein and your body
actually has a this amazing thing that
recycles damaged protein and this
condition or this mechanism is called
autophagy so when you do prolonged
fasting because protein is so important
it'll take that damaged protein and
convert it into amino acids to make new
proteins and so this is very very
therapeutic so just as a side note if
you do prolonged fasting and you don't
feel very good
it could mean that you need you know
certain nutrients like B vitamins
electrolytes salt but it also could mean
that you might need
amino acids so I don't recommend taking
protein but I would recommend if you
don't feel very good when you do
prolonged fasting is to take as a
supplement not throughout the day but
maybe once or twice a day and a good
amino acid complex now if you have just
the right amount of amino acids it won't
then convert to sugar and this is one of
the problems with consuming too much
protein the excess is not stored it's
converted to sugar and so if you eat
just the right amount of protein that
your body needs it will replace the body
tissue and give your body what it needs
but without turning it into sugar or fat
and as far as human requirements goes
that would be if we're looking at pounds
you would multiply
0.64 times how much you weigh okay and
that would be the number of grams of
protein you would need per day if we're
talking about kilograms you would
multiply 1.6 times your kilograms in
weight and that's how many grams of
protein you need per day now that's just
on average it could be a little bit more
if you're younger and you're an athlete
could be a little bit less now what's
really interesting about this whole
topic is recently I bought two horses
right because I live on a farm and um
you know trying to figure out what to
feed a horse because going into buying
horses there's a couple of conditions
that everyone says you have to be
careful not to overfeed them because
they get
things like hay belly where their belly
becomes extracted because they're eating
too much grain they might get this
condition called laminitis which is like
this inflammation of their foot which in
humans would be comparable to having
this inflamed tissue right beneath your
fingernail that's connected to your your
finger can you imagine having that
inflamed and trying to walk on it and so
a very severe form of that is called
foundering where you have this inflamed
foot and then all of a sudden this horse
can't walk and then you get what's
called a lame horse you know which is a
very terrible condition so I wanted to
know a little bit more about what's
really behind all this stuff so I found
a fascinating
of that that doesn't recommend feeding
your horses grain and apparently and
this all makes sense to me because I'm
in the health field the arthritis that
the horses get the ulcers that they also
get is all coming from either too many
grains or when a horse is put on um new
spring grass it's very very high in
fructose where if you eat too much
fructose you can get inflammation and
create all these problems it happens in
humans all the time we're on this
fructose diet and we have way too much
of it well horses are the same thing
normally in the wild the horse is not
confined to a barn or a a pasture
they're able to travel migrate and eat
not just grass but eat legumes and other
things and of course with a lot of
exercise to burn that off and so with
horses they'll continue to eat until
their protein requirement is satisfied
right and unfortunately in the spring
the grass is very high in carbs it
doesn't have much protein and so they
will just keep eating and eating eating
until they get enough protein well this
vet gave me some really good advice to
feed the horses legumes right and
Alfalfa is one but the other one is soy
soya is a legume that has basically
twice as much protein as grass and of
course I'm very much against consuming
soy for humans but apparently when you
have soybean meal they take out they
extract the oils that oxidize and that's
where you get that high omega-6 fatty
acid which is inflammatory and you're
left with this product with amino acids
and of course I would also try to
recommend getting the organic blend but
the point is if you feed these horses
legumes right they'll get the protein
and they won't overeat and apparently
he's been doing this for many years
working with lots of clients and has had
a lot of great success with these
problems with horses so the same thing
that's happening with humans is
happening with animals for some reason
we have this idea we have to feed horses
grains and have to be in a barn and they
have to do this and that but you just
want to look at nature what do they do
in nature naturally I mean when someone
goes on a diet what do they do they they
search out how to do a diet they go to
Google and to handle an appetite they'll
say well make sure you drink more water
eat more fiber to fill you up and make
sure you have a lot of the small snacks
through the day to prevent overeating I
do remember when I used to have a carb
breakfast man would I I would be hungry
an hour and a half later I would be
hungry in the evening right and then
when I switched to a protein breakfast
which I I don't do that now because I
fast until lunch but the point is when I
had eggs or meat hamburger or steak for
breakfast
boy that really handled my Hunger I was
satisfied I felt the best and that was
simply because I was achieving my
protein requirements without going over
the requirements just had enough and I
did really well now just to fully grasp
this information it's really important
to understand the translation of those
grams into quantities of protein and to
get more information on that I put this
video up right here check it out